[Music]
filming for dissonance 3 has wrapped and
we just can't get our hands on enough
juicy details
thanks to Disney's d3 deeps videos and
the stars instagrams
we have gotten some amazing
behind-the-scenes looks at the final
movie in the franchise keep watching to
find out our favorite behind-the-scenes
look from the set of descendants 3
trying to find out all you can about
descendants 3 so are we be sure to
subscribe to stay up-to-date and now
we've got the best behind-the-scenes
moments from descendants three
father-daughter selfie there's no doubt
about it dub Cameron's selfie game is on
point we just can't get enough of all
the awesome selfies she posts with the
rest of the descendants cast members on
July 9th 2018 she posted a selfie with
none other than Cheyenne Jackson that's
the guy who is playing Hades in
descendants 3 we know we know there are
some fan theories about who mouth that
is but there's a good chance it is
actually Hades we can't wait for this
story to go down but first check out
these two hanging out together just look
at this adorable photo they look like
they are totally related don't they
their chemistry is strong AAF and Dov
had the sweetest things to say about
Cheyenne she called him beam of light
trapped in the human body that is one
major compliment Cheyenne must be pretty
awesome he certainly doesn't sound like
a villain to us
Duff says he's the best Hades we could
ever ask for if they have this much love
for each other off screen we can't wait
to see their on-camera chemistry it's
too bad Dov didn't accidentally leak
some spoilers about Hades role in the
movie we want to know more scalp
massages
speaking of dub Cameron we just loved
one of the videos she posted on her
Instagram apparently she is the
designated Scout massager on set because
she's got long nails this video shows
her with her hair braided before her
purple wig goes on casually rubbing
booboo Stewart's long luscious locks
she says booboo is her main scalp
massage customer boo boo may be hiding
his eyes but DAF looks so ridiculously
happy we can also hear an off-camera
conversation between a couple of other
people talking about a friend
memories could that be Cameron boys just
casually hanging out while these two are
having a scalp massage and just look at
the way Dov leans in to cuddle booboo
they are total friendship goals Deb said
her mom took the video which means at
least one cast members family is on set
this feels like one big family vacation
and honestly we want in
seriously Dov is absolute perfection
she's so sweet and you can tell that she
loves her cast mates just as much you
have to if you're ready to give a bunch
of scalp massages to your coworkers we
just know that she'll be lifelong
friends with other VKS
they just look like they all love each
other and it's the cutest thing ever
kenny ortega dog whisperer dude the
campus mutt might be one of our favorite
characters from The Descendants movies
you know even though he is a dog because
let's be honest dogs are the best and it
looks like he might be one of the
directors favorite characters to the
official Disney descendants Instagram
account shared ad3 deets video on July
21st 2018 and it's all amazing
behind-the-scenes moments from
descendants three on one of the first
photos you can see Kenny Ortega cutting
the dog who plays dude and looking
absolutely in love it sure looks like
dude is enjoying it - speaking of dude
did you know the dog who plays him is
actually female Paisley is the adorable
dog behind the character but dude is a
boy in the movies in descendants - when
dude gets the ability to speak he is
voiced by Saturday Night Live star Bobby
Monaghan and where do we know Kenny
Ortega from well he was the awesome
director and choreographer behind the
High School Musical movies he's no
stranger to Disney Channel original
trilogy's we see a lot of photos of the
actors so it's pretty awesome to see a
photo of dude and Kenny to be honest
heard the type of people that would get
more excited about a dog on set than any
other cast mates - core 4 for life were
pretty sure that the core for BK's are
one of the best Disney Channel on-camera
friendships and the reason they are so
convincing as besties is because they
have so much love for each other in real
life on the last day of filming
Sophia Carson aka Eevee posted the
greatest Descendants selfie the four
friends are all hugging each other in
the makeup trailer the bed
thing about this photo is you can see
how much they resemble their characters
in personality
Karen boys has a huge goofy grin on his
face just like his character Carlos does
a lot boo boo looks happy and a bit
mischievous just like Jay and Dov and
Sophia both have very mal and Evie
smiles on their faces even though
they're dressed in fluffy pink bathrobes
Sofia's photo caption is a little letter
to the world and her co-stars she gives
a huge thank-you and believes there
could never be enough words to express
how grateful she is she tells us that
they will forever be our Evie mal Jay
and Carlos besties we absolutely loved
the photos of dub Cameron and Sofia
Carson remember in the first descendants
movie where mal says she always wanted a
sister and Evie said that now she has
one okay we might have cried a little at
that scene it sure looks like the two
actresses carry over their best friends
turned sisters mentality into real life
the video that the dissonant Instagram
shared on July 20th 2018 has some
amazing shots of the two friends one of
our favorites is the one where Sofia has
her arm around of and they are looking
at Sofia's phone it shows their
on-screen and off-screen friendships
perfectly the last photo of them in the
deep three deets video is another with
Sofia's arm around Doug someone snapped
this photo from behind so we know they
aren't just posing for the paparazzi and
the added bonus of this photo is we
finally get to see the back of their new
costumes
check out those purple leather dragon
wings on now we love that her costume
remains dark even though now herself is
choosing to be good these photos are
just perfect childhood friends we don't
get a lot of behind-the-scenes photos
from China and McClain but what she does
post is absolute gold China plays uma
the Pirates daughter of Ursula who makes
her debut in descendants - she posted
the cutest selfie with Cameron Boyce on
July 2nd 2018
Cameron is flashing his signature goofy
grin but China has her arm wrapped
around him with a fierce AF look on her
face they burst worked with each other
on the movie grown ups when
cameron was just nine years old and when
cameron landed a role on the Disney
Channel showed Jesse China was one of
the first people he told it is super
cool that these two lifelong friends got
to act together again maybe they will
get to act a lot more together in their
careers because they have such great
chemistry we will be seeing China again
in descendants three she did tell us it
wasn't the end of the story after all
Sunset Drive we know some of the best
footage happens when shooting ends and
that's probably when some of the actors
best memories are made to thanks to
sophia carson we definitely get a feel
of what it's like to be behind the
scenes with all the actors sophia posted
the sweetest little video on instagram
it was one of their last days of filming
before the whole franchise wrapped
emotions were running high and we can
totally see it in this little clip Sofia
Cameron and boo boo are in the backseat
of a car on their way to their hotel
they are driving through Vancouver and
Sofia shows us this gorgeous sunset out
the car window she said it was perfect
in every way do we agree she even said
her video to some bittersweet music and
it gave us all the feels we would have
loved to be in the car with them but
following sophia carson on instagram is
pretty much the next best thing and his
camera never stopped grinning he's got
to be one of the happiest people in the
world night shoots filming a huge movie
like the simmons three isn't always easy
dub Cameron's gives us a look into the
craziness that is a late-night shoot on
July 6 2018 she posted a video on her
Instagram they are on their way to film
and you can hear duck screaming night
shoots
Cameron voice is getting the shoulder
massage in the backseat and dove is
holding a tray from Starbucks she tells
us she is already two coffees deep they
must have been exhausted at this point
and Cameron Boyce reveals he isn't
always a family-friendly guy he asks
what is going on and he nearly dropped
an f-bomb on us we can hear Sophia
Carson in the front seat Shane pray for
us all they've obviously reached the
state of exhaustion where everything is
hilarious
well not everyone has the people in the
very back don't look is happy to be
awake filming tonight but that cast must
be like a really fun sleepover Dov is so
great at giving
to peek at what life is like when you're
filming a Disney Channel movie are you
going to miss her descendants post as
much as we are
Harry hooks watermelon dub Karen's
Instagram videos are giving us life on
July 13th 2018 she posted the funniest
video of Thomas Doherty aka Harry hook
it turns out Thomas is just as tough in
the real life at least he is when he's
fighting fruit we can tell they are in a
hotel room after filming Thomas still
has a bunch of Harry hook eye makeup on
after a day on set Dov tells him that
they need watermelon stat but they don't
have a knife so what does Thomas do he
legit just punches the watermelon open
isn't that crazy
that is such a pirate thing to do maybe
it would have been easier if he had a
hook hand
he swears it doesn't hurt because he's
tough but there's no way that didn't
sting a little she is as shocked as we
are that punching a watermelon actually
worked she calls her boyfriend a Willie
one and he certainly is these two are
adorable and we love that we got to see
a funny moment after filming make a wish
dub Cameron and Sophia Carson are
adorable friends amazing actresses and
absolutely hilarious but the best thing
about these two is that they are
legitimately kind people both actresses
posted photos from the very special day
on set at the beginning of July 2018
three little girls from the make-a-wish
Foundation got to meet their idols Evie
and mal Make A Wish Foundation grants
wishes to kids who are terminally ill
the girls came dressed like VKS
and Sophia called them warrior
princesses we loved up Cameron's photo
with all of the visitors making kissing
lips at the camera and you can tell
Sophia just op that we loves these kids
doesn't this just make you love these
two actresses even more it had to be
such a humbling experience for the cast
and we just know it made those little
girls so happy make-a-wish Foundation is
awesome and so is the cast of
descendants we're so glad those girls
got to visit the kingdom of auradon we
want to know what's your favorite
behind-the-scenes moment so come let us
know in the comments those are all of
our favorite behind-the-scenes moments
from descendants 3 subscribe to the
things to stay up-to-date with
everything we
know about the new movie thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]